[Música]
dá logo na ativa na infância quando
minha mãe usa como escudo na situação de
alcoolismo
naquele momento aos sete anos de idade
conseguiu uma situação de servir como
apoio a uma pessoa adulta uma criança
tem que ter uma responsabilidade tão
grande é diferente começa a ter um
raciocínio rápido da condição de vida
melhor e aí a gente chega à fase adulta
o movimento social anunciara antes da
história do banco mesmo a mudança de
vida daquele povo se dava pela
construção da via pública lá da beira
mar onde muitos daqueles pescadores
foram vindo a um local que simplesmente
jogar aquela população e construir suas
casas ea casa de papelão e aquele povo
se organizava de forma a garantir sua
sobrevivência mas aquela luta aguerrida
do ceará que as pessoas
eles estavam água luz telefone mas
aquilo parecia e as pessoas começavam
incomodado um seminário no movimento das
cebs lá pelos anos 80 década de oitenta
e cinco agentes dentro do seio da
comunidade a gente cria um seminário
habitável
que projetava 10 anos e ali a gente já
conseguia vários parceiros conseguimos
um projeto que a gente conseguiu dar uma
condição melhor para o bairro construir
um espaço mais adequado conseguir mas
falta a água luz telefone e aí a gente
percebia que o povo ainda continuavam
dando à comunidade porque é muito
difícil mas a gente conseguiu organizar
o povo de forma que ao terminar os dois
mandatos do governo
a gente já pensando em voltar para o
ceará surgiu a oportunidade de fazer o
primeiro banco da amazônia
o banco pine anbar e aí a gente começa
com a indagação de pouso seja ninguém
supera a pobreza sozinho e no mesmo
modelo de do ceará
nós organizamos as comunidades chamamos
para dentro
a forma muito parceira nós e os
moradores nós que eram os moradores e os
próprios moradores da comunidade todos
ali o princípio da incomodação em que
nós poderemos mudar nossa casa a nossa
rua o nosso bairro e aí nossa estratégia
daquela comunidade a partir da
organização comunitária moeda técnica
nossa moeda é da economia pesquisa e aí
nessa pesquisa apontou que nos saímos de
comércio que tinham duas pessoas
trabalhando com sucesso isso projetou a
prêmios no qual temos oito melhores do
brasil e nós estamos entre os 20 e nos
colocou que a gente ganhou vencedor para
instalar que nós pontuamos todos os
questionamentos da onu
e aí nós estamos concorrendo melhores
práticas do mundo
então para nós é uma coisa assim
muito provável porque partiu da
organização comunitária do momento em
que eu me senti incomodado o meu vizinho
e contagiei outro agente junto venceu
uma problemática que era esta econômica
cade é a vizinhança então assim temos o
crédito do produtivo e saímos uma escala
agora criamos em torno de 10 mesmo nessa
crise dez novos números são bastante
significativo que quando nós fizemos a
primeira a primeira pesquisa é um milhão
assim aberto e e ali naquela estratégia
de ter um crédito próprio moeda própria
de um aval solidário de envolver os
atores banco à economia logo ao trabalho
novos negócios o empreendedorismo e
novos negócios muitos negócios de 40.000
atendimento porque nós atendemos todos
os ribeirinhos nós pagamos todos os
projetos sociais do banco
então nós temos então isso acontece que
muita gente
com isso o que significaria os números
o desenvolvimento aquecimento do
comércio
o empreendedorismo empoderamento e uma
comunidade feliz que tu tem alguém que
pode chegar junto
pode mas que você junta outro mais outro
que 10 mil com 10 e 20 e assim a gente
vai mudando nossa história de vida
a gente passa a agregar valor
naquele projeto que a gente tem mas além
de agregar valor às pessoas vivem mais
feliz e daí a gente trabalha outros
projetos dentro do próprio instituto com
as mulheres do programa bolsa família em
vários números que tranquilo mas lá fora
quando meu filho sai um celular
ele pode perder a vida então isso faz
com que eu possa gerar renda para a
família eu posso ajudar esse pequeno
menor qualidade de vida e essa
olha hoje no projeto ci e de do banco
comunitário no atendimento e no
envolvimento de toda a comunidade que
está fazendo um grande diferencial
o projeto ceci para nós mulheres
possibilidade de futuro pessoas
melhorando a vida de cada um e na
oportunidade o meu muito obrigado e
dizer que nada é impossível
aquele que tem coragem é perseverante e
trazer as pessoas a terem um pouco mais
de felicidade
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]